Một đây chưa còn là hàng lận hai không hay lắm
Một đây xong đã là hàng lận của trong năm mới năm trước
Ờ
Anh cũng xem thì cái chuyện là mở
Mở cái gì ăn đòn tạo điện này
Đi dưới này của
Bởi vì sẽ nó mở
Sợ trong ngon
Mở trong trình thức vô cùng lớn
Phu của bởi học sinh không qua
Em muốn thọng lix sửa chờ này hơn
Mình phùa phải không
Đi ở đây là biết
Nhưng mà mình nói lượt
Sạch là phùa
Tôi với cả phương này
Đi học chỉ mong người có người này tham quan về mà mình nhiều nhiều hơn về lix sửa
nhiều hơn về những chiếc sửa
Nhưng rồi
Vậy thì thế giới ở đây là một trong những cái khóc được sửa hiệu quả nhất
Chả nghiệm thực quan, tộn bị cạm xuống
Bằng đi từ lâu hơn các đất nhiều lần sau đó
Chỉ sát
Bằng bảo sâu cho nghiệm sâu
Mà chỉ không bao giờ mình nhằm
Đi lý trình lưỡi bạch lòng
Gặp họ rồi
Hãy bảo sửa chứ
Không kìm chứng
Anh nghĩ sao anh anh nhầm
Bởi sâu như là mà bảo tăng anh thấy không nhầm
Chả nghiệm này có riêng không
Hãy đi cầm về tham quan
đi cầm
Dạc tham quan, nó tàn và lời
Bảo một lần là tránh nghiệm
Bảo trả
Cậu ra đây
Không ăn cậu cẻ này
Hãy bảo tích một vẻ mà xin như bà đu
Ở
Anh cần nạn để uống bảo một dù hành cây ra
Không cần bái cây ra
Nhà, follow để xem tiếp trả nghiệm cảy bảo tăng
Hả nôi